There is a mommy pooch.
There is, but you can't tell.
This little halara skirt.
This thing is adorable.
I love it. This little buckle is real.
You can buckle and unbuckle it and keep it on.
The first one.
Mama's got some thick thighs,
baby. Saving lives.
But for real, it's got this super stretchy waistband,
like all the things that hell are is known for.
And it's literally little athletic shorts.
But the little skirt on top covers everything you don't want to show.
It's literally the cutest thing ever.
I'm gonna go to summer concerts.
This lightweight material.
I know it's like, for working out,
but in the summer in a concert,
this is gonna be the cutest thing ever.
There's big time discounts for first time buyers of the TikTok
Shop is like right here.
There's free shipping and free return.
So even if you get the wrong size or you don't like the color,
you can always exchange it and get the one you like.
I am summer ready with this thing.